la justicia china ha ratificado la
condena a muerte al ciudadano canadiense
robert los de schallenberg había sido
detenido en 2015 cuando intentaba
trasladar más de 200 kilos de
metanfetaminas escondidos en ruedas de
automóviles desde china australia fue
condenada en un principio a 15 años y en
un juicio posterior el aumentó la
condena a la pena de muerte canadá habla
de proceso político y de condena
arbitraria alude a las fechas porque
días antes había sido detenida en canadá
la heredera de huawei menguan joe a
petición de estados unidos por violar el
embargo eran también días después fueron
detenidos en china michael spyborgs and
michael kobryn que han sido juzgados por
atentar contra la seguridad nacional
canadá habla de rehenes judiciales con
los que pekín estaría intentando
presionar a su justicia en el proceso
contra men se acerca el desenlace
después de dos años de tensiones
políticas porque esta semana se encara
ya la recta final al proceso de meng y
también se espera que china haga
públicas las sentencias a los dos
michaels